[Music]
um
can i let me ask you a quick question
before we wrap up getting wealthy like
we're talking nine figures liquid net
worth wealth
getting wealthy is it is it really hard
to do it just from cash flow or do you
think you have to sell it sell something
sell a business sell real estate sell
something capital gains versus income
you're saying liquid so not paper
not not your paper net worth
liquid which includes
things that could be traded in 30 days
um very hard very hard to do just off
cash flow i believe
um i think you know
it's just much slower right because you
can i mean just look at the basics right
like
when you sell something you're going to
sell it for some multiple
of the free cash flow that it's going to
generate for you right and
so so just by definition 10 or 20 years
sometimes it's 5x sometimes it's 10x
sometimes it's 20x sometimes it's 3x
whatever there's different multiples for
different industries but like
fundamentally it's a multiple which is a
multiplier on how fast you're going to
get the money the value out so let's say
to get to 100 million
uh whatever number of years that would
take you then have to divide that by
five and that's like how fast at minimum
you could have got there just selling
the asset um and getting and taking the
5x multiple right so so you know of
course you can get there but
do i know ways you can get there with
the same speed i don't think so because
even those are like i take the cash flow
i invested in a thing
and then that thing grows faster and
like i can sell my stake in that so you
know because it's like you you have a
choice so you could spend your time you
know you could spend your time building
a service or some type of business where
you can make significant cash flow two
three million dollars a year not work
that much but it's not necessarily an
asset that could be sold so there's a
few businesses like this or it could
just be like
um
like
the way the this podcast gets paid like
it's not like a particularly maybe but
maybe the podcast isn't a good example
but it's not you know what i mean not
necessarily an asset like your maven
course your maven course is not an asset
that could be sold but it could
potentially make many millions of
dollars a year versus you just say you
know what screw it i'm not doing that
because i have to build a business that
could sell
so
do you prefer do you think cash flow or
or
an entity an asset that is independent
of you and can be sold
um i don't know i don't think do i
prefer is really the right way to think
about it it's like you need both right
like for example
um
i you need both for two reasons one is
maybe you're going to use the cash flow
to invest right maybe what you're going
to do is you're going to buy great
assets and let them compound over time
well where are you going to get the cash
flow to begin with right when we had
andrew on that last week he's like i
i took the cash flow from the design
agency of meta lab and i used it to buy
majority stakes and all these other
businesses
and then let those compound over 10
years and like boom you know so he
reached you know that goal and more uh
doing that
and so you you know maybe you need the
cash flow to make those investments
right like if you have no cash flow how
are you gonna invest in anything and
secondly
um i like to live a good lifestyle so
sometimes casual businesses are great
because it's like yeah
sure compounding is awesome
but so is you know like [__] gucci
shoes or whatever i choose your choose
your thing you're into like yeah gucci
shoes like sometimes those are better
than like this yeah dude whenever i hear
an old asset
whenever i hear buffett talk about the
long term and like patience i'm like
[__] you're like 95. like there is no
long term there is you don't have pain
you shouldn't have patience anymore you
should have like you should immediately
spend whatever you want to spend there
is no such thing as a long-term view for
you
at the same part
let's see like the headline sampara
colon to warren buffett
[__] you're 95. there
well i'm just like you know like if you
want to do the mix you have to be fine
but like and bezos talks about those two
he's like i'm like i mean you don't
really who cares like you know just live
life how you want to live you got it
yeah so i've always like why are you
delaying it it always pissed me off i'm
like why are you delaying to have the
best time of your life when you're like
old and don't even want to do [__]
like you you don't have to do that
anymore
yeah yeah for sure and you know
some people are happy along the way
that's that's fine but like
uh yeah i feel like you had it i feel
like you asked me this question because
you had an opinion or a story so let's
just skip because i think you have a
good opinion or story on this
i don't have a no i don't have an
opinion yet but i'm like with my life
now it's like i can i think that in
i think in six
i think in a matter of six months i
could probably create a business from
scratch that does a million dollars a
year in profit it would be based off of
like my image i'm not saying i have that
i'm just saying like i'm sure i could do
that plus with like a couple other side
projects i think i could very
realistically have two or three million
dollars a year in cash flow
easily but very but yeah easy and maybe
i do already have that i don't even want
to say i do or do not but
i
but like
if you did that would have been a weird
way to say it would have been a weird
hypothetical but okay let's continue on
i got some cool [__] going on i'll say
but and i'm thinking about where do i
spend my time and i'm like is it
actually worth it like or should you
just not care about cash flow and build
something that's like much bigger that
you could sell i don't know i'm just
trying to figure i'm like where do you
actually spend time the real answer is
what gives you most joy yeah exactly and
and like
uh whether
you don't work backwards from do i want
cash flow or do i want long-term you
know capital gains that's not like the
starting point of a decision
um you kind of just need to make sure
you're winning in one way or the other
uh don't be weak in either area or like
don't be weak in both basically is like
the way to do it like for example you
could buy a home in san francisco you're
going to have terrible income from that
property it's not a good income property
because in most places san francisco
your rent the rent you can charge
somebody is not going to
out pay the mortgage plus yeah it's
going to make a three percent cap cap
but you can go buy you know some home in
whatever you know houston or something
like that it can cash flow thousand
dollars two thousand dollars a month and
it's good income property but it's you
know gonna appreciate super [__] slow
whereas the san francisco home
you know in 10 years is going to have
you know whatever more than doubled in
value
and so you know it's there's
appreciation properties and income
properties the same thing like
i think you just do whatever gives you
the kind of whatever's whatever gives
you juice today and you think might give
you juice going forward and then you got
to say all right before i do this i got
to make sure it's going to be strong in
either one of these either it's got to
be awesome for cash flow or it's got to
be awesome for for
appreciation and if it's awesome for
cash flow basically i'm just going to
use the cash flow to buy assets that are
going to appreciate with somebody else
doing the work instead of me doing the
work it's you kind of end up at the same
point either way
yeah
i don't know i just been thinking about
like how to spend time you know who's
killing it
and has done a really good job of like
putting off making cash is
our friend nick huber
i am an investor and so i get to see
some of the numbers of his storage deals
and
i don't think he crushed it
like in terms of personal cash flow for
a long time but like the way that things
have compounded i'm like oh holy moly if
you just eat [__] for like six seven
years and pick the right asset things
look really cool
yeah
yeah i think he's done great and also i
think he is like
i think he personally has great terms
for with his investors meaning like i
think it's quite favorable to him yeah
incredible in a bad way but like he
makes sure he gets to eat
right whereas at the beginning if you
have no capital you like
you know you sort of make a deal with
the devil in a way where you're like all
right i'm going to take no management
fees no acquisition fees and a low carry
i think now he's like look i'm good and
i know it so i'm going to take a higher
fee higher higher acquisition fee and
i'm going to
take you know my healthy carry um so you
know good on him i think a lot of people
in real estate are able to do that
pretty well uh i know somebody's
crushing it in real estate and they
they do just that they they have like a
you know
fifty percent carry on the deal or
something something crazy and they're
like yeah because
my deals are big hits and i win
so like it doesn't make sense for me to
do this at any less than that
there's this uh that's like
next level winning
all right and then i forgot to tell you
this but this is the most important
thing uh i can't believe we didn't talk
about this earlier to be honest with you
because if you're listening to this and
you like what you're hearing right now
and you haven't gone and subscribed to
the my first million podcast wherever
you get your podcast
then that's the thing you've got to do
there's nothing more important than
doing that right now and don't do it
because i said to do it
do it because you want to do it do it
because that's who you are
there's this awesome you know who foo
fighters are you know dave girl dave
grohl's the lead singer foo fighters
yeah and they've been writing hits
forever before that he was the drummer
nirvana so he's like just wrote hit
after hit for a long time and someone
asked him about uh he's like
um
you know you write hits and and what's
your process and like
uh a a fan was asking about old music
and but and he stopped he goes wait a
minute let me cut you off here he goes i
don't write deep cuts
i write hits
and it was just like he's like
everything i write i read it to be a hit
sometimes it is sometimes it isn't but
it's all meant to be and that's like
your real estate friends he's like i
write hits that's why he gets that 50
carry
exactly exactly
and respect i i respect somebody who's
like i'm playing the game
and i play to win the game you know i'm
not playing something else
i'm not going to tell you i'm not
playing the game i am playing the game
and playing to win that's actually like
uh i really respect people who just
clearly play the game and they're like
open about it like yeah i play the game
i'm playing to win and here's you know
like good if you if you dislike the game
or dislike me that is
your your choice and i actually dislike
people that are the like
uh virtue signal types where it's like
they are playing the game but they'll do
anything in their power to like
make it look like they're not playing
the game and there's a lot of that like
in silicon valley there's a lot of that
here's how that plays out that i see
there's
person starts the company
bullshits about like why they're doing
the company or why this problem is the
problem they decided to spend their life
on technology like
you're you know
you're doing this because
it's good business not because you
really wanted to help
you know small to medium-sized
enterprise businesses save money on
whatever right like
that wasn't your actual intention you
probably like that that you have happy
customers and that they're good you know
you're helping them
but like let's be real
uh taking away the money
have you ever seen on silicon valley
we're saving the world one cloud
processor at a time or some [__]
exactly
it's like yeah and then they're like
they're like
they're like uh someone calls them out
they're like dude this is all rich guy
like kid rock just was the singer for
the for the uh for the show and he's the
poorest guy here
yeah exactly
and so so i think silicon valley you see
that a lot you'll also see that with the
origin story about like you know why
they decided to do this you're like oh
are you sure you decided to do this
because you know your cousin got
diagnosed with this you know rare thing
and that's why or
or was it that you ran paid ads at five
different products and this was the one
with the highest click-through rate
because i'm pretty sure when i was
talking to you it was this was the
highest click-through rate cool that's
my company right like there's a lot of
that um so the other one is
the guy who started dollar shave club um
i saw an interview with him and some of
the times he's like i started dollar
shave club because i was just sick of
going to walgreens and i had to ask them
to like open up the razors and then
another interview he was like he's like
man my father-in-law is like crazy and
he likes us to buy random stuff and one
time he bought a shipping container full
of cheap razors and we just had to
figure out a way how to sell them all
yeah exactly that's why we did it
exactly
and you know i'm in the two percent of
the population i think you are too where
we're like oh sweet respect for trying
to flip the storage container and then
realizing there's a business there
versus like you know you know the kind
of like the shark tank version of the
story which was like we were just so fed
up with our options right and like i get
again i get it i've done that
i might do that again
but am i a little bit disgusted by it
yes uh same thing with
the same thing with i'll do that usually
when i have business partners not when
it's my own business um like when i'm
when i'm the only when i get to just be
a cowboy on my own i'll just do what i
want be like yeah i don't care if this
is bad for the business it's fine the
other day i ate a i ate an entire jar in
one sitting of peanut butter from it was
the jiffy cheap [__] and i just felt so
bad about myself but i didn't regret it
and that's kind of like how you feel but
i wanted to do her stuff for my friend
mission statements are like a pint of
and jerry's like if it feels good doing
it and you may not regret it but but
you feel guilty about yourself
the the other version of this is like
people who on twitter are like
uh they call this like [__] posters or
they're like you know they basically
they basically try to signal like you
know
i'm not gonna just
i'm not one of those
investors who blogs about content and
tries to yeah i'm a cool man i'll tell
you the real deal and i'll i'll make
jokes and blah blah it's like they're
the ones trying to carefully curate
their brand more than anyone if you
actually meet these people they're like
so conscious about their brand
uh and like you know how how many
followers they're getting and like how
viral their stuff is going and like
they are you know like uh
they're
they are so meticulous about that stuff
while trying to give off their
appearance it's like bed head right it's
like oh no i just woke up like this it's
like oh are you sure you don't use a
product called bed head that like you
know like makes it look slightly messy
but like you know you're actually
carrying where every strand of hair goes
and so you know i have more respect for
like um
people who are like yeah like
you know like pomp or sahil or they're
like yeah like people really like to
hear about bitcoin so i just tweet
bitcoin [__] all the time it's great
like i like bitcoin and they like
bitcoin so i'll just tweet like i'll
just set up a calendar i'll be like yeah
i'm gonna tweet bitcoin stuff because i
figured if i get a big bitcoin following
that'll be really really good for me
or like you know sahaja's like yeah i
put it i put out these threads
about these like finance topics because
i think i'm good at it and they go viral
and then it gives me all these dope
connections
versus like you know i just want like i
feel that knowledge is um
you know knowledge needs to be
accessible for all and free and that's
why we need to democratize knowledge
yeah i want to democratize financial
knowledge like i used to work on wall
street and the insiders know things that
the rest of us don't so i quit my job
and started writing twitter threads
about finance to democratize finance
it's like no
no no no no you didn't do any of that
you wanted followers and so you did what
it took to get followers have you
noticed how the word democratize is the
new disrupt
democratizes like you know what is
democratized
uh it's the new democratize is the new
like
um no offense but
that's a democratized democratize is
like about to fool you this is good for
me and not good for you but i'm going to
fool you by saying i'm democratizing
something for you buy my service buy my
product
yeah by the way i do all that i do this
myself i again i know it i spot it
because i got it right i've done all
this before with my e-commerce brand
i've done the origin story thing with uh
my fund i do this too like my fund is
called the all-access fund because i
wanted to give access to every access to
all to be able to invest in the deals i
do
do i feel good that other people get
access to good silicon valley deals yeah
sure is that why i did the fun [__] no
that's not why i did the fund right i
did the fun because i was writing checks
and i wanted to write bigger checks and
more checks into more companies and more
and that was more than my personal
bankroll would allow so i raised money
from other people to do that and i get
you know like
so now i get to write more checks into
more awesome companies that's why i
raised the fund not because i wanted to
democratize access to like you know
angel investing for like you know a a
middle school teacher in uh tennessee
i can't stand democratized we're gonna
democrat democratize this by only
charging you fifty thousand dollars for
this piece of clothing instead of
i'm like i've seen people like we're
gonna democratize knowledge and it's
like a five thousand dollar course like
[Laughter]
you can democratize these nuts
what do you think ben was today uh
were we with it or what i thought today
was a hit i thought today was a huge hit
this is uh
yeah other than like the steph smith
episodes or robbed your dick this is uh
this is a plus territory ah great are we
gonna have to cut out my uh democratize
these nuts
[Laughter]
and then so we have to plan the mfm
summit so uh i agree that making a
destination is cool i have a thing that
i uh you're gonna have to bleep bleep
out what i'm about to say but i know the
thing i know the thing yeah yeah i got
the guy i got a really like famous house
that person might be interested in
hosting us i don't know if that's just
gonna be a dinner right like that's
gonna be like no no no no no no no no
we might be able to do a proper thing
there but i don't know if the logistics
are going to work out so i think but but
i think that we could do like something
outrageous you know we have to think
about what outrageous means but i do
think we can have something outrageous i
think a cruise ship i like it that's a
it's not a bad idea a cruise ship or
like some type of famous venue or [__]
we could just go to hawaii
just do it like in the beach in hawaii
we can figure something out but we do
need to do it people fly out like if
people are gonna have to travel for it i
think
to get the value again the the easiest
hack is first make it a couple days
where people get to hang and meet each
other so do it make it like a two day
thing and then and then secondly
um
just make it already fun if it was just
a vacation if there was no content on
top but it's like then you combine
some content
uh getting to meet us and getting to
meet other people in the community plus
already it was a good like kind of
vacation type experience
then that's cool right and like i don't
know let's do like
bring a fitness component bring a like
let's bring all the components of the
stuff we talk about where there's like
you know experiences beyond sitting down
and listening to people talk it's like
why not do a group workout or like let's
get an mma guy to like you know take us
through a set like take people through a
session or something i don't know like
something like that
down all right let's schedule it i i do
do you like that 500 price mark price
point
this i mean we should do this as an nft
no doubt we should make this an nft and
then only nft holders can attend and
then they could flip their nft to
somebody else if they want to but make
it a limited number of nfts
uh for this
down all right that's it
all right that's the episode
[Music]